all right hope you had a great
magnificent tremendous weekend I you
know mine was mine was pretty it was a
good weekend for the most part there was
one disturbing aspect of it I took my
kids out yesterday to the lake a
beautiful day hot day went to the lake
did a little bit of fishing that's not
the disturbing part disturbing was on
the way home when I got this idea I was
really excited it was such a hot day I
said you know I had this idea that I'm
gonna get them a nice treat I'm going to
get them slushies from the gas station
my kids have never had slushies before
they're five years old
the twins are they've gone through five
years of life I'd never had a slushie so
I was really excited now as a kid
slushies were one of my favorite
childhood treats especially on a hot day
having a slushie I mean that nothing
beats it right so I take him into the
gas station I'm I'm I'm hyping it up a
lot and saying oh this is this I love
this when I was your age you guys are
gonna love this and I get him the
slushies and they don't like slushies my
kids five years old I would have killed
a man for a slushie when I was their age
literally and they they said it tastes
like soda fizz which yeah that's the
point and they didn't like them so this
is just it was crushing for me as a and
there's there's there's there's nothing
more difficult than that as a parent
when there's something when there's
something that you cherish from your
childhood and you're so excited to tell
your kids about it and to introduce them
to it and they don't like it it's
similar to the first time I showed my
kids the movie babe which was one of my
favorite kid movies growing up as a kid
and they didn't like that movie now they
you know the talking Pig movie they like
Peppa the pig which is a you know that's
the British pig they like that they
don't like the American Pig so what I'm
beginning and they don't like slushies
they don't like American pigs American
talking pigs anyway so I'm getting this
vibe that my kids are communist
basically and I didn't raise them that
way that's not it's not my fault the
Russians got to them somehow and I'm
just as horrified by it as you are all
right um several big topics to get into
today but first I want to tell you about
helix sleep you know we got we got one
of these mattresses our selves and I
feel like I'm a good person to offer an
endorsement of it because I'm usually
not a great sleeper I have back issues
shoulder issues men
two issues I'm falling apart the
mattress didn't do anything for the
mental issues I have to say that's you
got to talk to a counselor for that but
as for the back and shoulder problems
it's been great it gives me kind of the
firm support that I need what I'm
sleeping but is also a soft mattress at
the same time really the best of both
worlds and I've been sleeping like a
baby on it ever since
well not like an infant because they
don't sleep it more like a one or two
year old I've been sleeping helix sleep
has a quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you very simple I took the
quiz myself just takes a couple minutes
it's it makes a lot easier the whole the
whole mattress shopping experience
becomes easier whether you're a side
sleeper hot sleeper you like a plush or
firm bed with helix there's no confusion
no more compromising helix sleep is
ready - the number one mattress 4 by GQ
and Wired magazine and CNN calls it the
most comfortable mattress they've ever
slept on just go to helix sleep calm
slash Walsh take their 2 minutes sleep
quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life and for
couples helix can even split the
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they have a 10
year warranty and you get to try it out
for a hundred nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it so but you will love it so you
don't have to worry about that helix is
offering up to 125 dollars off all
mattress orders for our listeners right
now get up to 125 dollars off at elix
sleep calm slash Walsh that's helix
sleep calm slash Walsh RuPt $125 off
your mattress helix sleep calm slash
Walsh ok so the Democrats in the House
on Friday voted unanimously to pass
something that they are in true
Orwellian fashion calling the Equality
Act and in so doing they have proven yet
again as if we needed more proof that
the Democrat Party is a radical anti
science cult the legislation is absurd
and horrifying of course it's not going
to become law because it's not going to
make it through the Senate and there's
no way Trump would sign it but it does
show what will certainly happen if the
Democrats ever control the entire
government again because this thing
passed unanimously it would not have
done that a few years ago it would have
been seen as too radical
but now the whole Democrat Party is
radical extreme even the ones who get
credit for being moderates are really
just as crazy as the rest of them and a
good example of that is is good ol mayor
Pete who we'll talk about in a minute
but let's talk about what this law does
the law would expand the Civil Rights
Act of 1964 to ban discrimination
quote-unquote based on sexual
orientation and gender identity not
gender that's already illegal but on
gender identity but what is
discrimination based on sexual
orientation and gender identity well
there's there's plenty that has left
vague in the bill and intentionally so
it doesn't specifically say for instance
that a Christian Baker would have to
bake a cake for a gay wedding but that
is the implication because this would
codify into law the idea that any form
of discrimination against someone based
on sexual orientation is an infringement
on their fundamental human rights and if
that's an infringement on their
fundamental human rights then is it an
infringement of their rights to refuse
to bake a cake well obviously it isn't
not based on any coherent or rational
definition of human rights but the
Democrats are not working from a
coherent and rational definition of
human rights so from from their
perspective yes it is and so I think
that's part of the implication of this
law let me read a little bit from the
bill itself it says discrimination can
occur on the basis of sex sexual
orientation gender identity or pregnancy
childbirth or a related medical
condition of an individual as well as
because of sex based stereotypes each of
these factors alone can serve as the
basis for discrimination and each is a
form of sex discrimination so they're
establishing gender identity in that
realm of sex discrimination it goes on a
single instance of discrimination may
have more than one basis blah blah blah
lesbian gay bisexual transgender and
queer referred to as LGBTQ people
commonly experience discrimination and
securing access to a public
accommodations including restaurants
senior centers stores places of or
establishments that provide
entertainment health care facilities
shelters government offices youth
service providers including adoption and
foster care providers and transportation
forms of discrimination include the
exclusion and denial of entry unequal or
unfair treatment harassment and violence
this discrimination prevents the full
participant now here's the important
part this discrimination prevents the
full participation of LGBTQ people in
society and disrupts the free flow of
Commerce so the 90 big now if they're if
a Christian business owner says I don't
want to partake in the gay wedding does
that mean that that prevents the
participation of the LGBTQ person in
society and disrupts commerce again
obviously not but from the perspective
of these crazy Democrats yeah
and then it goes on you just just I'm
not gonna read this whole thing but if
it just establishes this idea that okay
these are fundamental human rights and
you can't be discriminated and it
becomes clear that yes cake bakers would
be in trouble with a law like this any
Christian business owner would be in
trouble over at the daily signal Ryan T
Anderson one of my favorite writers
summarizes some of the objectives of the
law I'll read his bullet points for you
yeah he says number one the Equality Act
what it would force employers to cover
abortion and medical professionals to
perform or assist in performing
abortions number two the Equality Act
would force employers to pay for sex
reassignment procedures in their health
insurance plans and require medical
professionals to perform them number
three the Equality Act would force all
schools and businesses to open their
women's bathrooms locker room showers
and sports teams two boys who identify
as girls and two men who identify as
women for the Equality Act would would
could be used to force the military to
pay for reassignment procedures and
forced the military to accept recruits
suffering from gender dysphoria who are
not combat ready five the Equality Act
would force faith-based adoption
agencies to either violate their
conviction that every child deserves
both a mother and father
or to stop serving children in need
altogether six the Equality Act would
force a variety of small business owners
to violate their beliefs about marriage
sexuality and gender seven the Equality
Act in general threatens the freedom of
speech freedom of association and free
exercise of religion of countless people
okay so let's go through a couple of
things here the main and most immediate
and explicit thing this bill does it
seems is force everyone in society all
institutions schools businesses etc to
pretend that a biological male who
claims to be a girl really is a girl
this is a law that says if a dude says
he's a girl then he's a girl which
logically is no different from a law
that says if someone says the moon is
made of marshmallows than it is if they
say it that it's true and you have to
acknowledge and affirm that truth or you
are infringing on their rights which is
madness it is trying to impose a
biological unreality onto society in the
process it would of course destroy
women's sports because it would mean
that any dude who wants to join a girls
sports team can just walk in no
questions asked
it's not even like they have to be on
hormones or they have to have already
done the sex change or whatever sex
change of course is euphemistically
namely there's no such thing as a sex
change operation or sex reassignment
just think about that phrase with sex
reassignment like you can just reassign
your sex I'm gonna reassign it you can
if sex is not assigned in the first
place it's just what is who you are it's
what you are
there's no assigning that goes on it's
just what you are you might as well say
I'm we're gonna do a height reassignment
I'm gonna reassign I've been assigned to
be six foot one but I want to be 8 foot
3 and so I'm going to reassign my height
it makes no sense
so this
this is a fundamental human right and
and a man who says he's a girl has a
fundamental human right to force
everyone to pretend that he's something
he isn't now even worse is the danger
that it puts women and girls in because
under this law it is now a fundamental
human right of a man to walk into any
girl's bathroom no questions asked if
you try to prevent him you're infringing
on his rights as a human being
I mean liberals have been shrieking
about how a woman's autonomy and her
right to her body and her right to
privacy are being stolen by laws that
simply prevent her from killing her
children but now these very same
charlatans in the Democrat Party are
going to really infringe on a woman's
right to privacy by allowing men into
her bathrooms and her locker rooms
remember abortion the so called supposed
right to abortion that was located in
1973 by an all-male Supreme Court they
found the right to abortion in the right
to privacy which which also is not
actually in the Constitution but if the
right to privacy means anything I mean
if we have a right to privacy then
wouldn't you have that right in a
bathroom and a locker room isn't that
one of the the main areas in life were
you if there is such a thing as a right
to privacy you would want to be able to
call upon it and say I I am claiming my
right to pray but no they're saying no
you don't have any right to privacy
there if a dude wants to come in and he
says he's a girl then that's it he's a
girl well and what do they do I was just
thinking about this but because we're
told that there are countless genders
their you know their unlimited number of
genders so what if somebody just makes
up a new gender and says I'm gonna walk
into the women's but what do you do with
that what do you do with someone who who
says he's well he's not a
Noora or a man he's a you know he's a
flop a doodle that's that's my gender is
flop a doodle and and he says I want to
go into the do you have to make a new
locker room for floppy doodles or can
the flop doodle go wherever he wants how
does that work I mean and I'm saying
that's my gender you can't tell me it's
not oh you're telling me I'm not a
flapper-doodle how dare you that's what
I identify as I feel it deep in my heart
and soul that I'm a flop of doodle and
you can't tell me otherwise another
thing about this is you see how
Democrats are constantly trying to
hijack the civil rights struggle in such
a demeaning insulting borderline racist
way where the Civil Rights Act initially
was about actually giving equal rights
to black Americans who you know up until
the middle of the 19th century were
enslaved okay were treated as property
and then for another 100 years they're
thereafter they were really legally
prevented from participating in society
not because they weren't allowed to go
into a women's bathroom if there were a
man but oh they couldn't go into any
public restroom unless there was one
specifically for their for their race
they were prevented from take they
really were prevented legally from being
recognized as full American citizens as
full human beings and from enjoying
those rights and privileges and that
obviously was a terrible evil injustice
so part of the Civil Rights Act was
about addressing that okay now Democrats
and the radical left and that those of
course are the same groups I'm trying to
hijack that struggle byuk waiting you
know think about the situation that a
black man or woman would have been in in
you know in say the 1950s before the
Civil Rights Act and they're trying
say that what transgenders are in the
same spot no a so-called transgender
person can do all of the things that the
rest of us can do there's nothing that
you can't do you can go do whatever you
want you can say whatever you want you
can go anywhere you could take part in
any activity you can go in any store you
could you could you could participate
fully in society as far as bathrooms and
and and locker rooms go you have the
right to go into the locker room a
bathroom that aligns with your
biological sex which is the same right
that the rest of us have and it's the
same limitation that the rest of us have
that we're not allowed to go into the
locker room or bathroom that doesn't
align with our biological sex neither
can you so what's happening here is the
LGBT people again they're not looking
for equal rights they're looking for
special rights they want something that
the rest of us don't have that is the I
don't have the ability to go into any
bathroom I want but what the LGBT people
say they're saying I want that right for
myself I want to be able to go into any
bathroom man or woman either one and if
you won't let me then you basically
enslaved me I am like a slave now such a
cynical exploitation of the very real
struggles of black Americans in this
country it's disguise its gross its
disgusting to try to exploit it in that
way what other point here you know the
full LGBT acronym is right now it keeps
expanding but right now I just looked it
up the full acronym right now is LGBT
tqq i aap and that stands for lesbian
gay bisexual transgender transsexual
queer questioning intersex asexual Ally
pansexual okay so and when we talk about
you're not allowed to discriminate and
they say LGBT that's really shorthand
for the whole acronym right so what does
that mean you can't discriminate against
what so you can't just
against questioning people what does it
mean to discriminate against the
questioning our our the questioning
being discriminate is there is there
anywhere you can go in society where
there's a sign up on a window no
questioning people allowed here
questioning people may not apply I mean
is that happening anywhere has anyone in
this country ever been discriminated
against for questioning what does that
even mean or a lie you can't be no
allies allowed allies get out it's just
it's it's completely ridiculous these
most of the people in this acronym
that's not even you you wouldn't even
know if you met a person like that I
don't even know what discriminating
against them would even mean
pansexual yeah so the pansexuals are
being discriminated against how so and
once again
I mean if you don't go as long as you'll
go around announcing to everyone hey I'm
a pansexual now if you say that to most
people they'll say ok whatever I don't
even know what that means
good for you pansexual are you attracted
to pancakes I honestly I don't know what
it means but you you can be that it's no
one cares really just you don't be but
you're not to go around announcing it
any more than I go around announcing my
own sexual orientation I don't I don't
walk up to someone and say hey my name
is Matt heterosexual how are you I don't
do that
so because it's none of their business
it's inappropriate it's weird if you're
a pansexual whatever that means you
don't need to necessarily announce that
and if you don't then there's there
would even be any opportunity for
discrimination so the whole thing is is
just ridiculous all right mayor Pete was
on Fox News last night he did a Fox News
townhall wait now I really want to know
what pansexual is hold on I'm described
to I don't I don't think it's attraction
to pancakes okay so not limited in
sexual choice with regard to biological
sex gender or gender identity
so pansexual is you're just attracted to
any everybody without any so no
discrimination there okay so that's what
pansexual pansexuals can't be
discriminated against either not that
that's happening anyways it's that
that's not actually happening but now
good now it definitely can't happen so
that's great mayor Pete was on Fox News
last night did a a Fox News Town Hall
and remember this is supposed to be the
moderate reasonable Democrat character
but watch this there's been a lot of
focus this week about the states that
have voted to restrict women's rights
but there's also been a movement in the
other direction New York State also this
year passed a new law which
significantly increases a woman's right
to accept to an abortion it used to be
the exception was it after I think it's
24 weeks to protect the life of a woman
now the new law is to protect
the health of a woman which is a much
more lenient standard and I guess the
question is do you believe at any point
in pregnancy whether it's six weeks or
eight weeks or 24 weeks or whatever that
there should be any limit on a woman's
right to have an abortion I think the
dialogue has got so caught up on where
you draw the line that we've gotten away
from the fundamental question of who
gets to draw the line and I trust women
to draw the line when it's there
so just to be clear just to be clear
you're saying that you would be okay
with a woman well into the third
trimester deciding to abort her
pregnancy look these hypotheticals are
usually set up in order to provoke a
strong emotional right and it's not
hypothetical there's six thousand women
a year who get abortions in the 30s
right representing less than one percent
of cases pregnancy
let's take ourselves down so let's put
ourselves in the shoes of a woman in
that situation if it's that late in your
pregnancy that means almost by
definition you've been expecting to
carry it to term we're talking about
women who have perhaps chosen a name
women who have purchased a crib families
that then get the most devastating
medical news of their lifetimes
something about the health or the life
of the mother that forces them to make
an impossible unthinkable choice and the
bottom line is as horrible as that
choice is that woman that family may
seek spiritual guidance they may seek
medical guidance but it's that decisions
not going to be made any better
medically or morally because the
government is dictating how that
decision should be made okay so first of
all here all those trained seals in the
audience applauding while this person
advocates killing babies at 38 weeks and
this is the answer that every Democrat
has to give now they have to endorse
killing babies all throughout pregnancy
through every stage for any reason which
is again the continued radicalization of
the Democrat Party but I do want to note
that everything he said at the end there
was totally bogus
and wrong where he's talking about well
he what are the situations where
somebody would very late in pregnancy
when they've already got the crib and
they've named the child what are the
situations where they would get an
abortion and and mayor Pete pretends
that he knows what he's saying isn't
true that well there's no way anybody
would make that choice
that only encompasses 1% of all
abortions yeah but rape and incest only
accounts for 1% and Democrats talk about
that all the time so the fact that it's
only 1% according to you is it doesn't
mean we shouldn't talk about it and 1%
considering how many abortions happen in
this country hundreds of thousands every
year 1% accounts for thousands and
thousands of abortions so thousands of
times women are getting abortions very
late in pregnancy he says it's only if
the mother's life is in jeopardy that is
just not true that is a lie it's a total
lie I've addressed it plenty of times in
the past and I will once again address
it because it's simply not true
if a woman at say you know what 32 weeks
for instance has a cataclysmic medical
complication and she can't continue the
pregnancy that does happen but the thing
is at 32 weeks in in you know the third
trimester she can they can deliver the
child and there's a very good chance the
child will survive 32 weeks is a very
good chance the child where survived
with modern technology so there's no
reason to kill a child the point is at
Minh the third trimester late in
pregnancy if there is some sort of
complication you've got to deliver the
baby no matter what even if you're
getting the abortion there is still
going to be a delivery the only
difference is in the abortion you kill
the child first and then by stabbing it
with a poison needle and then you
deliver it but that X
stress step of killing the child first
there is no medical reason for that at
all that doesn't help the woman it
doesn't preserve the woman's life that
is just an extra medical step which
carries with it medical a huge quotes
around medical by the way the huge scare
quotes around it it's not medical at all
this is just murder but that is an extra
step that carries with it extra risks to
the mother and obviously a huge risk to
the baby who is going to be killed
more than likely by the procedure unless
the abortion fails which does happen
also and then in some cases the baby
will just be killed afterwards if it is
a failed abortion which is what Ralph
Northam and in Virginia advocated for
there's no reason for that you just
deliver the baby
send it to the NICU for medical
treatment and then if the woman doesn't
want the child you put the child up for
adoption and and there will be a very
long line of people waiting to adopt
that child there'd be no problem finding
a home for that child no problem at all
so this is just untrue Democrats
to pretend that a late-term abortion is
the least egregious kind of abortion
because well it only happens for medical
reasons but it is definitely the most
egregious kind not only because it's so
late in the pregnancy and what you have
now is a fully-formed baby who visibly
looks like a baby not just because of
that but because it's it's it is uh you
you could just delete you're delivering
the baby anyway so just deliver him do a
c-section you don't need to kill him
first
there's just no reason now there's no
reason to kill a baby at any stage but
at that stage you're going through the
process of delivery anyway so let him be
born alive and give him a chance alright
um staying on this topic for a moments
Tommy Lehren sent out a tweet over the
weekend and he here's the tweet I'll put
it up on the screen it says to those
arguing with me over the Alabama law I
am NOT saying life doesn't matter I am
asking you if you honestly think an
all-out ban is going to stop abortion do
you think government is the answer do
you think it's effective or does this
just or does this ban just make you feel
better now you know Tommy I have no
issue with Tommy I worked with her
briefly when I was over at the blaze and
I think she's a you know we didn't I
lived I didn't I didn't live down in
Dallas where the studios are down there
but I you know my experience with her a
little bit of especially I think she's a
nice person she's perfectly fine I have
no problem with her but this kind of
thing and I've it's it's been known now
for a while when Tommy larren came out
in support of against the Alabama law a
few days ago it was treated as this
headline story now we've known for a
couple of years now that Tommy is
pro-abortion
which is very unfortunate and I just
don't think
conservatism is supposed to be about
advocating Liberty basic human rights
that's what conservatism is supposed to
be and if you don't have the right to
life then you can't have any other right
and so your ability to be a effective
advocate for the conservative position
is severely hindered if you're not
advocating for the right to life which
is the foundational right upon which all
the rest lay but we've known that about
her the argument you that she puts
forward here is just bad it's a it is a
straw man it makes no sense you know we
want to we're pro-life because what
makes us feel better what do you think
that government is the answer is an
all-out ban on abortion going to stop
abortion ok well the answer is no nobody
thinks that when you when you ban
abortion there's not gonna be any
abortions anymore and abortion is done
and it's a utopia no one thinks that but
I would ask you this Tommy do you think
that an all-out ban on rape has stopped
rape from happening has an all-out ban
on carjacking or you know armed robbery
or homicide which abortion does homicide
but other forms of homicide has an
all-out ban on any of those things stop
those things from happening no in fact I
would even argue it seems to me quite
likely that the ban on rape which we
have in every state in the Union I think
it's probably likely that it has never
actually prevented a single rape from
happening in that if someone decides
that they want to rape another human
being they have the desire to do it and
they find the opportunity to do it I
doubt
to stop because it's illegal I don't
know if there's ever been a person says
you know I really want to rape someone
and I have the opportunity to above but
it's against the law so I'm not gonna do
it no because if someone is a total
dirtbag and they're an evil person
and so they have this desire in the
first place which means you have to be
able to be so deep into the depths of
evil and darkness to even have that
desire and if they have it then there's
not gonna be prevented by the law the
reason why most of the vuss have never
raped anyone are never killed anyone
it's just because we have absolutely no
desire to do that we're not that kind of
person but if someone is that kind of
person then I think it's probably likely
that the law will not stop them but the
reason why we have laws against it is
because it is a an evil violent act
which harms another person and in a
civilized society acts like that
behavior like that is illegal whether
how effective the law is and actually
stopping a thing ahead of time who knows
but it's against the law because we are
a civilized human society and there is a
lot of value in simply
making that statement as a society and
saying we do not approve of that that is
not tolerated we will not accept that
and then all the on the other end of it
you can try to enact some kind of
justice although you can never undo this
terrible thing that happened
you can enact some kind of justice by
punishing the person who did it and that
also has value and so when I say that my
so maybe I should correct myself a
little bit I say that laws against rape
have never prevent prevented a rape
I think laws against rape probably
haven't stopped a rapist from initially
committing that act against another
person but if when after it happens you
put that person in jail you probably
have prevented additional rapes from
that person by putting them in jail so
there is so there is some preventative
value in that case and so that's it if
the because it's are you gonna say that
because we have laws against rape we
have laws against murder that we're
pretending that government is the answer
no but government has a role has a
function in society and to a prohibit
and punish violent acts against other
people I mean if the government doesn't
have that function or that role then
what the hell is the point of government
that's one of the most basic roles of
government if it's not supposed to do
that then I don't even know why we have
a government we may as well have no
government then so it's the same thing
with abortion so it
one says well you have a law against
abortion it's not gonna prevent any
abortions even if that's true I still
say it should be against the law but I
don't even think that is true because
you know we've there's been 60 million
abortions since roe v wade that's an
average of 1.3 million a year are you
gonna tell me that even if abortion was
illegal we would still have that number
of abortions so you're telling me nobody
would have been dissuaded from getting
an abortion if it was illegal I don't I
don't believe that because something
like rape or homicide of a born person
thing about that is most of the time
it's one person doing it to another
person most of the time there is no
third party involved but with the nature
of abortion cloaking itself as it does
as a medical procedure usually there's a
there's gonna be a third person there's
a third party involved there is the
quote-unquote doctor if you're not going
to get that third party involved and
that means you're left using a coat
hanger some gruesome thing like that so
you got to tell me that every single
woman who has gone to a so-called doctor
for an abortion if she had not been able
to go to the doctor she would have used
a coat hanger or something like that she
would have gone to the supposed back
alley for the abortion you know I don't
think so I think actually that laws
against abortion would dissuade a fair
number of women from getting an abortion
I think there are a fair number of women
who would say that's illegal you know I
don't want to go do the back-alley thing
so maybe I'll just have the kid and put
him up for adoption instead I think that
that is a thought process that would
probably go through a lot of women's
minds if abortions were not completely
legal and easy to to get just by going
to a Planned Parenthood down the street
so I do think it will dissuade and
prevent a fair number of abortions how
many I don't know but also it that part
of it is not the point the point is it
is an evil violent
against another human being and that's
why it should be illegal for that reason
period alright um let's go to emails
Matt Walsh Oh at gmail.com
Matt Walsh Oh at gmail.com this is from
Ashley says let's see here yeah Ashley
says I really enjoy your show and I've
been watching since the beginning
carcast days as a pro-lifer I have to
say I was a bit stumped when someone
said if abortion is murder then
miscarriage is manslaughter and a
spirited debate I honestly didn't have a
great response and would like to hear
your take I personally don't believe
miscarriages are manslaughter but if I
believe abortion is murder which I do
then wouldn't it be honest to say
miscarriages are in fact manslaughter
anyway I appreciate your time and all
you do for the light pro-life movement
sincerely Ashley hi Ashley yeah this is
a common argument from pro Boortz and
I'm not sure why because it's very weak
there is a clear difference between a
miscarriage and an abortion a
miscarriage by definition is something
that happens accidentally naturally
because of sickness or injury or some
other problem out of anyone's control
now if it's an intention on this
miscarriage then it's not a miscarriage
it's an abortion so we're not talking
about a miscarriage anymore
the idea that you can't criminalize
abortion without criminalizing
miscarriages is exactly the same as
saying you can't criminalize infanticide
without criminalizing Syd's
which is sudden infant death syndrome
there are tragic cases that I'm sure
you've heard about where an infant dies
suddenly often in their crib and not
because anyone did anything to cause it
obviously that's different from someone
intentionally smothering their infant or
killing them the shaken baby syndrome or
or in some other way
obviously the intentional harm to an
infant is evil and harm and and is evil
and therefore should be punished
but an accidental uncaused death of an
infant is tragic and not criminal so
you're not going to punish the parent we
all understand that there's no problem
in understanding that concept and
so the same and the same would go for
the distinction between someone dying of
brain cancer and someone dying from
being shot in the head obviously someone
dies of brain cancer no one is going to
jail for that that's a tragic illness
and that's all and we mourn it someone
gets shot in the head we want to find
out who pulled the trigger and put them
in jail so same thing miscarriage verse
abortion both are tragedies because
someone a human being is dying and a
miscarriage it's not anyone's fault and
so the only thing that we should do in
response to that is have sympathy for
the mother and the father but an
abortion is an intentional killing so
honestly I don't see the I just don't
see how so many people are confused by
this I don't think there's any force or
power to that argument at all
let's see this is see there's one other
I'm gonna save that one for tomorrow
this is from LA Klug says love the show
your show is my favorite on The Daily
wire I came from been stayed for Matt
the Magnificent Matt the Magnificent
well that's a good one before I asked my
question please bear in mind I am
pro-life on your side as a Christian
though not Catholic I'm Calvinist you
stated recently on your show that an
unborn child is human life that has
intrinsic worth that all human life has
worth I agree an unborn child is the
closest to sinless you can get though we
are all born in sin no one is good not
no not one shortly thereafter you
advocated for the death penalty for
rapists I'm not necessarily against
capital punishment but the rapist is
human and alive is he not what is the
difference exactly is it that he has
forfeited his worth by the commission of
a heinous crime so certain lives do
cease to have Worth and therefore must
end is that is it that simple am I
missing something
now you don't forfeit your worth but you
can forfeit your rights so a person who
commits a violent crime we all agree has
forfeited his right to almost everything
he's going to be locked in a cage now
and everything he does will be
controlled and monitored so a person in
jail has almost no rights
their First Amendment rights are
severely limited they have no second
Amendment rights most of their rights
are gone not all but most his Liberty in
general is gone because he is put in
this building he's not allowed to leave
that's one of the most fundamental
freedoms we have is freedom to move
around and go where we want to be put in
a cage and said you can't go anywhere
well that is a restriction on our
liberties but we all agree unless we're
in our gifts that yeah we've got to be
able to do that if someone is a violent
dangerous person yet someone even in
that case there's still a human being
they still have worth so we believe that
there's a standard of humane treatment
that's what we call it humane treatment
to treat someone like a human that even
someone in jail is entitled to but that
doesn't change the fact that he's lost
almost all of his rights because of his
actions so if we believe that a person
can lose almost all of their rights then
the only remaining question is whether
they can lose their right to life and
it's a little bit of a less difficult
leap to make once we've established that
yeah you can lose your rights and then
it did all the question is well which
rights can be lost and I think that yeah
a person can can lose that right just
says you can only lose your other
liberties through deliberate action on
your part
or I suppose through violent and
dangerous action that is you know you
can lose it through violent and
dangerous action on your part you can
lose your your freedom to walk around
and many of your freedoms even I guess
if it's not deliberate if you're you
know if you're a dangerous psychotic you
could still be locked somewhere for the
sake of society but either way it's
about your actions it's about
demonstrating that you are not the kind
of person who can be trusted to live in
human society an unborn child cannot
possibly have demonstrated that an
unborn child
cannot possibly have committed any crime
cannot possibly have victimized anyone
cannot possibly have demonstrated that
they are dangerous now you could say all
you want that always is an unwanted
child born into a poor family the
chances of them becoming a criminal or
very great well that may be true
statistically but you can't start
executing people based on the
statistical likelihood that they're
going to commit a crime in the future
this is not the Minority Report
obviously no this is about what have
they done and a person who commits them
the most heinous of crimes against
another person there is a very real very
credible argument you can make that they
have lost their right to continue
existing in human society that's all by
committing that act there's still a
human being but
as a society can just no longer tolerate
their continued presence their actions
are too evil they're too dangerous they
have made it clear they have told us
through their actions I don't want to
live in human society anymore I don't
want to be a part of it and so is there
a point where we say okay
I mean have it your way as you wish
this is what you wanted as I said I'm
conflicted on capital punishment so I
kind of wave her back and forth but
there definitely is an argument there
and there is no con you can be pro-life
and and for the death penalty because
there are two completely different
things being pro-life does not mean that
you oppose killing people under any
circumstance there are clearly
circumstances even if you're against
capital punishment you would still say I
assume that there are other
circumstances self-defense just war you
know I assume most people think that we
were justified in killing the Nazis in
World War two I rarely meet anyone who
would say otherwise even someone who's
against the death penalty so there are
circumstances but if we're going to talk
about circumstances we're killing
someone is morally acceptable I just
don't see how killing an innocent baby
could possibly fit into that acceptable
genre all right there's a lot here that
I'm leaving on the table that I guess
we'll get to tomorrow because we're just
running out of time but so we'll save
the rest for tomorrow and remember Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com if you have any
emails questions comments yourself and
I'll talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed hey everybody its Andrew Clavin
host of the Andrew Clavin show
conservative stop complaining about the
end of Game of Thrones it is one of the
great cultural wins for our size an
eight season long lesson on how a queen
let grievance politics transform her
into a tyrant it is a mini history of
the Democrat Party we'll talk about it
on the Andrew Clavin show I'm Andrew
Clavin